we're getting back to the good old days
jack where we used to make fun of aoc
all the time it was like she's the
biggest news right
we have this story from the daily mail
quote sell your 70
000 tesla critics slam learjet liberal
aoc for not helping her grandmother
after she posted photos of her puerto
rican home ravaged by hurricane maria
and blamed trump so here's what we know
about aoc first
first of all i i am not happy to see
that her grandmother is living in
in terrible conditions because of the
hurricane it devastated puerto rico i'd
love to be able to to help out there's a
lot of people
we should do like uh we should do like a
fun gift go for a gift
go for aoc's grandma her in in abuela
right or play
in in puerto rico yeah i normally i
would say yes but i kind of agree with
the critics
i'm not going to assume aoc bought a
tesla in cash
people like people seem to think that
you know this nico woman
she has a two million dollar apartment
she doesn't have two million dollars in
cash she got a mortgage
all right so she puts down it still
means she probably had like 20 grand for
closing costs and if she put on like
five percent
so she still has a lot of cash oh yeah
to buy it aoc probably put it down
no i mean right so aoc doesn't have 70
grand
she probably put a down payment she
probably got a loan for the car
but she ain't doing too bad apparently
she lives in that really nice luxury
uh hotel in i'm sorry luxury apartment
in dc with an infinity pool we heard
that story
so she's gonna she's gonna make
congressional salaries uh about 175 000
plus by the way you get per diem you get
mileage it's staff salaries
you're you're doing fine you're doing
very well i have to imagine she makes
money elsewhere
she's not i i doubt she's just sitting
on a congressional site well and we
already know though that she did have
that position with the justice dems and
there was that whole sort of like
and this was actually they got
investigated it's why they sort of
disbanded a lot of it because they were
trying to run
a political committee and a for-profit
uh firm but as both as the justice team
it was all
feeding each other it was almost
laundering cash right so it was like i
never accuse aocf laundry and cash
that's
i say almost because i can't make that
official assessment because i don't know
but
basically one company hires her
boyfriend
right and then all of a sudden he moves
in with aoc in new york how convenient
yeah things like that but this this is
the perfect example example of
it's it's not limousine liberal they're
calling her a leader jet literally she's
not a liberal
she's a socialist socialist what what
would we call that what's an expensive
thing that starts with the letter s we
can make a champagne socialist
yeah that's a shock you get the
illiterate a little bit of the
literature close
closely i should be socialist but it's
still a shock
i don't drink but but total um uh total
shout out to rachel bovard because i was
i
uh she gave a somali a presentation uh
some oh somalia socialist maybe there
you go
and i was i was enthralled she just knew
everything about it she's apparently
designing it for seven years
and i don't drink at all totally not my
thing but i was just really interested
in the stories
this is uh this is this is what we
consistently get i mean we had limousine
liberals for a long time
the people saying oh climate change and
they fly on private jets so climate
change they buy beachfront property
now you get aoc saying like my poor
grandmother and it's like lady you got
money
i'm not going to pretend aoc is the one
percentage this is this is a barack
obama's brother in in in africa
oh right right right that whole thing
yeah so this is this is the this is the
i guess the consistent uh message we
should expect from these leftists who
claim
to want to fight for the working class
or tax the rich it's like dude they're
rich
do they think they're working class like
aoc when she's she's educated elite now
she's in congress
yeah if you're i i'm i've this is
actually something i thought about a lot
as
i was so a lot of the the book i i wrote
like a year ago so throughout 2020 i'm
writing this right actually
yeah the answer to the book but i get
into all this stuff i get into socialism
communism anarchism
i get in all of it right and i kind of
just use antifa as the touch point for
all of it
and you know one and so i went back and
i've been i was like sort of speed
reading it
you know just to refresh myself and
going through it and you know
just really thinking about this issue of
the working class and the people who
claim to
represent the working class if you're
someone who claims to represent the
working class
you're probably not working class right
it's it's like
never happened it's it is so incredibly
rare because people who are
in working class they're they're they're
working they're they've got their
families they
you know uh you know they're busy
they're they're they're
living paycheck to paycheck and we want
to you know
obviously we want to have a system where
people like that can have a family and
can
have home ownership and don't have to be
in you know up to their years in debt
right
but and they shouldn't need these
massive expansive political movements
claiming
you know some sort of agency of acting
in their benefit because
you're just not you're typically either
you're either the new poor or you're
someone who's from that sort of upper
middle class
band of well i never really had any
meaningful rite of passage so
my you know finding myself finding my
knees on my center
finding my center is going to be helping
those who are less fortunate that i
they don't know how to help themselves
but i do it's interesting how new
classes emerge right you had like
the proletariat the bourgeoisie and then
there's that painting i don't know if
you've ever seen it where it's like the
workers and then the police and then you
know it's like a layer and then
the politicians are on top or whatever
you're the one where they're like
holding it up
yeah yeah yeah i see that so you have
like aoc who is certainly not the
working class
she is an educated elite bourgeois she
is
wealthy by global standards especially
in a six-figure salary nearly 200k plus
probably she makes money elsewhere she's
probably over 200 000 a year
she's really close to the one percent
really close but she's not i think one
percent is up to like 400 or something a
thousand a year to be one percent but
she's well off
but the more the the uh it's interesting
that there's not just the working class
and the landlords anymore or the
merchant class then it's all of a sudden
there's like
there are middle class people who are
also landlords because they own a single
property and they rent out part of it
right
so it's what ends up happening is you
get people like aoc who keep
looking up they see the ultra wealthy
and they say as long as i'm not them
i'm the working class although i don't
think aoc has ever actually produced
something i her
i'm not i i think to be to be fair you
know she's now
um uh she's in her second term as a
congresswoman
you don't expect a lot of bills to get
passed by someone who's you know this
just this new to the to congress or
anything but
what what is what has she actually given
to society that has helped you know
you know i'd love to see that i i really
do think that there's there's sort of
this struggle with aoc because
when she first ran she actually seemed
to be quite more populist than she has
when she's been in office you could
argue the same about trump by the way um
but you wonder if there are issues and i
seem to remember there were a couple
times where her and like matt gates
might have you know
tweets that were both in support of the
same thing um
in in some of these instances and you
wish that you could see
stuff like that going on where it's like
hey we you know
completely disagree on you know maybe
this
aspect of foreign conflict or you know
certain climate change provisions or
actually
i think it was climate change actually
it was a climate change thing where
where matt gates was on
um and you'd love to see something where
these these sort of this new generation
of culture warriors is actually finding
common ground
and you have to imagine that would
trickle down
to these device the divisive street
level of some of this stuff or the
divisive social media level or the
device of
you know the school boards and the
facebook groups and everything else
where instead of it's
oh i've got to defeat you i've got to
beat you i've got my team has to win
and so instead of making a team sport
out of it you say hey we're all on the
same team
and that's called you know it's kind of
cliche but that's the united states of
america we all live here
that's not true anymore can we do that
no i i understand you have a difference
of opinion
no i read that article for american
greatness i disagree with it i think it
went a little far
but i mean republicans right now are
paid to sit on their hands and watch
democrats ravage the system
right so so even right now with the
conversation about conservatives using
the language of the left
look at what they're talking about the
january 6th commission republicans
keep going exactly where democrats want
them to go
it reminds me of when i was younger i
was playing a game of chess i was like
18 and i was playing just this guy
and he was laughing and he said you can
only move where i let you move
right and uh he was right he was better
at me better than me at chess and he
knew
if i go here he'll he'll go here because
that's his best you know and then he was
he walked me into a checkmate and then i
you know had to learn and get better at
the game
so you look at what's happening right
now the left comes out and says january
6 insurrection
meanwhile we had a year plus two three
four years of anti-fuck extremism
i i remember watching in berkeley an old
lady was was standing in a park
in the uh uh was at mlk park and
samantha threw an m80 at her and then
she falls backwards someone was probably
like 60 70 years old
probably could have gotten really hurt
and i was like what is wrong with these
people
no commission no investigation not even
a commission on kovid
but the dems come out and say january 6
commission and yet republicans do
no it's political the republicans should
do
blm commission antifa commission and
then when they say january 6 republicans
just do not respond
at all in any meaningful capacity at all
like you didn't even hear him say it
watch jack say january 6 commission
right now
tim january 16th we should be
investigating antifa right now i want to
i want to get a bill on the table
to investigate antifa what do you say
ian you're here
all right although the democrats
wouldn't agree stop
walking into their room it's like i'm
watching it it's like it's
offense and defense right it's it's one
side is projecting the other side is
deflecting
so the the republicans and you've seen
this again
and again with the republican party this
is my party right where
they will count it as a win if they were
able to stop the democrats from doing
x right whatever it is and you see this
interplay again and again with the
republican parties well it's a win
because we stopped this the win because
we stopped that ah we
you know we couldn't get this to stop
where they couldn't get this one through
so that was right
no that's not a win right that's that's
that's stalemate that's neutral if
you're talking world war one trying to
work
slow defeat they are going to win
eventually if you allow them to continue
to take over every single institution of
society
every single cultural outlet of society
like has been happening they are
running the table with this because they
knew that their policies if they came
out
and just told you you know early on say
back in the 1990s
hey this is what we want this is what
we're going to do with america it never
would have flown in terms of public
opinion there's a
this famous quote from a great
philosopher and he said
never fight an alligator underwater oh
he was right
[Laughter]
ian said that yeah that's pretty good
what the i love it yeah i just came out
of nowhere and you're like wow that's a
good one
that's a good one but yeah yeah don't do
that no right that's what republicans do
they're going into the territory of the
democrats thinking they're gonna win
it's like bro you're on their home turf
you got to stand up for something and
talk about what the american people want
what your constituents want
but apparently i guess it wasn't wrong
when the democrats in the media were
saying
republicans just want to own the libs so
what do they do they let they say they
say
hey lib make an argument wrong your
argument about about the january sex
commission is wrong and then the whole
conversation the whole time
that all that anyone hears is storming
the capital right insurrection
then you go and ask a leftist about
anti-fun they go what's antifa
because republicans don't talk about it
right and so trust me this is why when
when joe biden comes out and says antifa
that's just an idea
right it's he's setting the frame he's
already setting the frame of now you
have to say
antifa is not an idea antifa is this
this and this and are they idea are they
not able they don't have an organization
they don't have a leader
they don't have a headquarters you see
this on the internet all the time every
time i tweet about antifa they say
where's their headquarters jack where's
their oh
tifa you know where's the where's the
headquarters who's the leader who is the
organization do they have ranks do they
need the uniforms actually they do have
uniform i say well they have unity
rights they have they have logos they
have flags they may not
have uh stated ranks but they do have a
hierarchy
in terms of their you know red green
yellow in terms of the black blocks
so yeah they do actually have all of
these things thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you